I challenge your leader to personal combat
(shouts of encouragement)
Shields up!
Have we got the side of a barn? Maybe they could hit that
(laughs)
Woah woah
Steady
No! Wait!
It's
My sister
Hello brother
Shall we talk?
Shall I address you as...
Megan, let's keep it simple.
And you otherwise Drago
Wise (chuckles)
I expected you to have the same
opinion of dragons as your brother does.
Come on.
Let's go for a walk
Peter
How's your sister?
Which way?
Okay
(cheers)
You're welcome
They always forget you need four to take me down.
Sheriff!
(frustrated grunting)
You see the dragon shape in the stars?
Draco
The eternal resting ground for dragons who are worthy.
You're worried that you won't gain a place
Your grandfathers surveyed the Kingdom from the air
Let me give you a ride, it's faster.
We can use the time to better understand the bond between us
I'll take my chances on the ground, thanks.
When you were born you inherited a gift.
A dragon hearts power.
The gift is mine now. We have to save this throne
Together
Dragonheart: Battle for the Heartfire on Blu-Ray June 13th